the Nikki remix I just dropped because
it seemed like she you know when she
chooses an all Queen lineup of artists
to hop on a remix that's got to be a
dope honor to be included in that
absolutely yeah she any I'm I'm so just
inspired by like Nikki Rihanna so many
women that I've I've had the chance to
cross paths with that really inspire me
have shown me so much love so
it's made me in turn be like okay I want
to do that for the other women that are
like coming up the other the younger
girls is because that I've only received
that you know like it gets weird
sometimes like music industry stuff and
girls but it's really just like I feel
like
to support what you genuinely like and
then like